[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de cette culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mardi 18
décembre finir l'année de manière
culturelle le théâtre montansier fête le
nouvel an avec georges feydeau une
création mise en scène par vincent
tavernier à partir d'une histoire vraie
et vannes place et fait réfléchir au
harcèlement la pièce ses fils a été
présenté à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt et à quelques jours des
vacances de fin d'année nous ferons
aussi un retour sur l'année 2018 un coup
d'oeil en arrière pour décrire découvrir
ce qui a fait l'actualité culturelle
dans les yvelines
à l'occasion des fêtes de fin d'année
manon varades aux journalistes de la
rédaction vient d'en haut plateau nous
faire découvrir deux ouvrages jeunesse
autour de noël
flâner au coeur d'une exposition à voir
un coup de coeur pour une oeuvre à
voisins le bretonneux
le centre alfred de vigny présente une
quarantaine de tableaux réalisés par des
artistes pour la plupart locaux
ses oeuvres ont été rassemblées par
espoir à tchernobyl depuis 1991
l'association du cinéma apporter de
l'aide à des familles a accueilli plus
de 1200 enfants et cette dernière
collecte est notamment destiné à aider
une jeune fille pauline à est né avec un
seul oeil et respirer par la bouche elle
va être encore opéré cette année parce
que bien sûr il ya la partie commander
des blocages des respirations par la
bouche a été fait très rapidement et
très bien donc ça aucun problème par le
nez pardon par contre tout ce qui est en
modification de la face pour accueillir
une prothèse oculaire correct
ça prend beaucoup de temps ça se fait
petit à petit c'est vraiment l'art sur
le moment qui m'a intéressé et puis
ensuite jeux et sports à tchernobyl
c'est une longue histoire avec voisins
le bretonneux
donc je trouvais que c'était intéressant
de l'île et 2 juste avant noël c'était
une oeuvre à la fois généreuse et et
puis il ya quand même de belles oeuvres
et si pour cette fin d'année vous alliez
au théâtre le montant sied à versailles
vous propose de terminer 2018 avec
georges feydeau ou plutôt une création
mise en scène par vincent tavernier
geneviève dichamp bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la codirectrice du théâtre
montansier feydeau rien de mieux pour
terminer 2010 8 12 comédiens en folie
sur une des meilleures pièces de feydeau
2h15 de rire de situations qui les plus
incroyables les unes que les autres dont
deux très beaux de ce quiproquo vente le
sens des quiproquos très bien monté une
mécanique toujours rythmé d'une manière
incroyable dans cette pièce la puce à
l'oreille c'est le titre on pourra
notamment découvrir raymonde chandebise
qui essaient de démasquer un mari volage
c'est bien ça tout à fait mais je vous
dirai pas la suite l'est nord est ce que
tous seraient révélés feydeau alors le
31 décembre est déjà victime de son
succès il restera juste les places à 5
euros
deux derniers moments que nous ouvrirons
à 19h45 nous faut être attentif tout à
fait et il reste quelques places pour le
30 décembre encore bien placé quelques
unes si on veut un tout petit peu
anticipée pourquoi prévoir des cdd des
séances comme ça en 31 décembre voici ça
se remplit les gens viennent keskisalo
les gens commencent à réserver en août
pour le 31 décembre
c'est une façon de commencer la soirée
de manière agréable avant un dîner ou
avec des amis ce qui est étonnant c'est
qu'on a des gens de toute la france
qui vraisemblablement viennent aussi
passer les fêtes en famille en région
parisienne les théâtres dans paris intra
muros augmente beaucoup le prix des
places pour le 31 mai nous on maintient
les prix habituel et donc c'est une
soirée très festive et très sympa ça
très beau cadre dans un beau cadre et
qui permet de bien terminer l'année de
commencer la suivante à la puce à
l'oreille c'est une création elle a été
coproduite par le théâtre c'est une
mission toujours aussi importante pour
vous alors c'est une mission de plus en
plus importante puisque vous savez qu on
a candidaté au label scène nationale et
qu'on est tout à fait dans les critères
et notamment en termes de production et
de coproduction on se sait investi de
plus en plus dans ce domaine dans la
diversité des esthétiques avec des
compagnies on va dire repérer et de
jeunes talents et rien que sur la
période janvier juin 2019 on est sur
onze création soutenue par le théâtre
alors des soutiens c'est de quelle sorte
c'est du soutien financier c'est du
soutien de salles peut-être vous mettez
à disposition le fait alors c'est
toujours du soutien financier et ce ne
sont jamais des préachats c'est de
l'argent qui est versée en coproduction
pour vraiment venir aider la compagnie à
monter le projet et puis ensuite ce sont
effectivement souvent des prêts de
salles la mise à disposition de la salle
de répétition
et puis ensuite l'achat des
représentations mais notre apport en
coproduction c'est un vrai apport c'est
pas on va dire des préachats déguisé
c'est vraiment de la coproduction pour
aider les compagnies j'insiste parce que
effectivement ça se fait de moins en
moins mais pour monter des spectacles il
faut d'abord avoir un budget de
production il faut du temps ci voilà
portrait vous disiez plus d'une dizaine
de créations programmées sur la saison
vous finissez 2018 avec une création
mais vous débutez aussi 2019 avec une
création
cette fois c'est un molière avec sur
scène excusez du peu
pierre arditi jacques weber et notamment
isabelle gélinas qu'on connaît plus dans
fais pas ci fais pas ça absolument donc
grand arthur créé en septembre à la
porte saint martin qui terminera dans
son exploitation parisienne le 31
décembre et qui arrivera à versailles du
8 au 13 janvier très importante mise en
scène de peter stein avec effectivement
une distribution d'excellence
effectivement certains rôles qu'on est
plus habitué à voir dans un autre
registre et c'est aussi ça l'intérêt du
travail qui a mené peter stein et c'est
un tartuffe qui vous réservera des
surprises aux pieds de quoi se faire
plaisir beaucoup de dates contrairement
aux feydeau finalement c'est que sur
deux jours ça dure toute une semaine
voilà sidati représentations dont une
matinée ce qui permet aux personnes qui
préfèrent sortir en journée et déjà
beaucoup de monde mais il reste encore
des places et je vous invite tous à
venir voir ce spectacle
alors on l'a dit vous faites beaucoup de
créations des productions marqué en 2017
ya quand même eu six nominations aux
molières ça motive pour continuer à
aller les compagnies ce qui nous motive
le plus c'est quand même le fait que le
public soit présent et qu'il apprécie
aussi cette diversité des esthétiques on
essaye vraiment voilà de montrer les
différentes facettes du spectacle vivant
à travers des textes différents qu'ils
soient d'auteurs contemporains d'auteurs
classiques de avec des comédiens très
réputé de jeunes comédiens pour montrer
au public on va dire la plus large le
plus large panel de ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui
en théâtre merci geneviève dichamp alors
pour ne rien rater de la deuxième partie
de saison du théâtre montansier et
notamment la pièce avec pierre arditi et
jacques weber
rendez vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et
d'ailleurs geneviève dichamp il ya une
date toute proche à ne pas manquer chez
vous c'est encore plus près que le
feydeau c'est aussi un molière cette
fois il est moins connu que le tartuffe
amphitryon et écrite par le dramaturge
français en 1668 la mise en scène est
signée stéphanie tesson regardez un
extrait je prends un site riant vous
avez bien souvent avait dit voilà on me
croit
amphitryon jamais d'autre que moi c'est
une histoire qui a interpellé en 2012
amanda todd se suicide
la jeune canadienne de 15 ans avait
publié une vidéo sur le harcèlement
qu'elle subissait depuis trois ans un
fait divers qui a choqué et qui a
inspiré evans placer un dramaturge qui
écrit ses fils à la compagnie ariane a
choisi de le mettre en scène la pièce
était présenté à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt elles sont 20 des amis depuis
l'âge de 5 ans aujourd'hui au lycée à
l'école sainte hélène différentes
ressemblante elles savent tout sur l'une
et l'autre elle n'oublie jamais une
amitié qui va se fragiliser une photo de
scarlett
[Musique]
écrit par evan placés en hauteur
canadien ses fils à est inspiré de
l'histoire d'amanda todd
la jeune canadienne a posté une vidéo
juste avant de se suicider en 2012 une
histoire de harcèlement ça raconte
surtout comment on arrive à l'intérieur
d'un groupe à se faire exister que non
et quels sont les rapports que peuvent
avoir les individus d'aujourd'hui avec
les collectifs avec les groupes et
comment de tout temps c'est compliqué de
tenir sa propre parole d'être ce qu'on a
envie d'être sur scène douze comédienne
professionnelle et 8 anatole uffheim
étudiants issus de la sq rabal théâtre
elles ont travaillé leur rôle pendant
deux semaines avant de monter sur la
scène de la ferme de bel ébat goethe est
trop sensible mais enfin des fois quand
il ya des scènes particulièrement
émouvante
j'étais au bord des larmes je me sentais
patrice et donc du coup voilà bien plus
les comédiens professionnels il était
très gentil avec nous mais j'étais
franchement adorable et du coup voilà ça
a contribué à rendre l'expérience
inoubliable
les comédiennes professionnelles avaient
une précision et une intensité de jeu
assez assez forte et du couple à nous
élever un peu dans notre façon de jouer
ces filles là est une pièce porté sur la
volonté de les changer une exploration
de la jeunesse de l'impact des mots de
l'identité on se sent forcément
concernés
vraiment je suis content d'avoir
accompagné mon fils pour regarder la
pièce quoi j'ai truc c'était très fort
d'un point de vue émotion c'était très
contemporain parce que voilà c'est une
histoire vraie c'est intéressant parce
que on peut lire beaucoup d'articles
voir des films en rapport avec ça et du
coup si ça a été mis au théâtre ça
apporte un autre point de vue en tournée
depuis 2010 est la pièce aux les
passagers les paroles crues elle décrit
des situations difficiles pour mieux
réfléchir et agir
[Applaudissements]
un sujet plus léger à présent pour faire
patienter les enfants qui attendent avec
joie le 24 décembre
rien de tel que des histoires de noël et
notre journaliste manon varaldo s'est
penché sur la question en forme annonce
bonsoir mélanie alors vous allez vous
avez sélectionné deux livres d'auteurs
qui sont yvelinoise oui alors le premier
s'intitule plus tard le lucas sera père
noël c'est le douzième ouvrage de
l'auteur mélanie chambres 1 c'est
l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui attend
impatiemment les fêtes de noël mais
lucas se pose des questions le père noël
vieilli il a une barbe blanche il n'est
plus tout jeune
l'enfant se demande qui l'aidera quand
il ne pourra plus déposer les cadeaux
il se dit mois plus tard quand je serai
grand je serai père noël il décide alors
de lui écrire les jours suivants lucas
s'applique à devenir père noël il fait
tout ce que le vieux monsieur ferait il
veut être digne de lui
le père noël est gentil généreux et a
toujours un mot aimable pour les gens je
peux donc m'entraîner à être comme lui
dès maintenant à l'école du cac écoute
sa maîtresse il est ses copains dès
qu'il le peut pendant la récréation il a
toujours un mot gentil pour ceux et
celles qui viennent le voir ça donne
envie
mais alors est-ce que vous avez un
deuxième vivre oui présenter il s'agit
d'un livre de véronique barbotan après
un ours au pays du père noël en 2016
elle a écrit le père noël à rambouillet
c'est l'histoire de techsoup un petit
tour se rencontrer dans son ouvrage
précédent
il était parti en laponie pour
rencontrer le père noël
mais il était très déçu car il n'avait
pas pu emmener ses amis avec le monde et
cette année le petit ours n'a pas pu
aller en laponie
alors c'est le père noël qui vient à lui
il va lui faire une surprise en venant à
rambouillet elle sera organisée avec ses
amis de la ferme qui sont les animaux de
la bergerie dans ce livre on retrouve
beaucoup de lieux de la ville de
rambouillet tout en découvrant la
aventures du petit ours avec le père
noël c'est aussi une petite promenade
dans rambouillet avec les endroits forts
comme le manège si l'hippodrome
donc du coup c'est l'idée c'est vraiment
de permettre aussi aux enfants de mieux
découvrir la ville de rambouillet pour
ceux qui habitent mais pour ceux qui ont
envie de la visiter et notamment pour
ceux qui veulent venir à la bergerie de
rambouillet véronique barbotan l'auteur
et l'illustrateur michel breton ont
décidé de reverser leurs droits à
l'association louis carles issimo qui
offrent rêve et espérance aux enfants
malades
car c'est ça l'esprit de noël mélanie le
partage et la culture est l'un des
meilleurs moyens de partager merci manon
ans mélanie chambrun publié aux éditions
un rêve d'enfant véronique barbotin apg
c'est comme édition découvrez des
disciplines avec des artistes programmés
au prisme la salle d'elancourt a lancé
ce week-end de nouveaux ateliers des
brunchs créatif
le premier se tenait ce dimanche avec la
compagnie de man la main de l'homme et
c'était vos images maintenant varaldo
[Musique]
avec human aubeterre clément d'azun
s'interroge sur la répétition du
mouvement sur l'engagement physique au
travail
il raconte à travers le jonglage un art
qu'il a choisi de partager avec un de
ces artistes de plateau avec la main
comme si elle à l arrivée par
l'initiation on a fait un peu de
foulards pour apprendre à jongler à
trois foulards on a fait un peu de
déquilibre d'objets ça veut dire
apprendre à tenir un objet en équilibre
donc là on a fait des plumes de paon
parce que c'est assez simple vous des
templiers au jonglage et et
s'amuser sa musique comme ça dans cette
discipline initier des gens qui
connaissent pas du tout cet atelier
s'inscrit dans une nouveauté celle des
brunchs créatif lancé cette saison par
la salle du prisme
ça fait partie des choses qui sont
importantes dans un théâtre il faut être
en mouvement il faut imaginer de
nouveaux moyens pour aller à la
rencontre des publics en douce et ont
des changes de partage et de
convivialité pour sortir un petit peu du
rapport traditionnel du spectacle de
rencontrer aussitôt de personnes ça
quand on vient à un spectacle c'est pas
toujours le moment propice pour échanger
avec son voisin de fauteuils voilà
pendant la la représentation la la c'est
le propos c'est de créer recréer du lien
mais du coup là le poignet plutôt away
plutôt comme ça un autre rendez vous est
prévu pour le mois de mai avant de
devenir trimestriel la saison prochaine
[Musique]
ce magazine est le dernier de l'année
2018 une année faite de concerts
d'expositions de rencontres
je vous propose de continuer ce numéro
en jetant un coup d'oeil dans le
rétroviseur et de revenir sur 12 mois de
culture
une pluie de stars dans les yvelines les
planches du département attire toujours
de grands noms de la culture en janvier
le théâtre montansier accueille alain
françon mettant en scène anouk grinberg
dans un grand théâtre russe les planches
théâtrales ont été foulés tout au long
de l'année par françois morel fanny
ardant joey starr ou encore patrick
timsit dans une adaptation d'un roman
d'albert cohen au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
j'ai mis trente ans avant de le jouer et
là je me dis qu'au contraire la maturité
va le faire progresser dans l'émotion
dans la simplicité dans le rien
justement aller vers le rien le non-jeu
l'émotion pure quoi 2018 année
anniversaire pour le cnvb le centre de
musique baroque de versailles oeuvre
depuis 30 ans à la valorisation du
patrimoine musical des xviie et xviiie
siècles
il a fêté ses trois décennies au sein
même du ministère de la culture qui lie
à 20 ans il y a même encore dix ans nous
ne travaillons pas du tout de la même
manière et c'est surtout cette évolution
qui est notable
d'une part la mondialisation c'est à
dire que centre de musique baroque de
versailles aujourd'hui est vraiment le
centre international de musique baroque
de versailles
et puis la deuxième chose c'est bien sûr
les nouvelles technologies le numérique
qui permettent de fonctionner de manière
totalement différente
[Musique]
de la musique populaire de la variété
française de didier gustin à christophe
willem en passant par mademoiselle k des
concerts pour toutes et tous
la culture est aussi une histoire de
renouveau le château de rambouillet a vu
rouvrir les appartements de l'empereur
le château de versailles le hameau de la
reine après trois ans de travaux trois
ans c'était aussi le temps pour mûrir
une création pris en compte pensé par
l'association vivre debout le théâtre du
sable et la compagnie black blanc beur
est présenté pour la première fois à
maurepas
[Musique]
ne dites plus la commanderie des
templiers seulement la commanderie
le lieu historique saint quentinois
change de visage une nouvelle politique
culturelle pour une nouvelle vie un fab
lab enfin une sorte d'incubateur qui va
permettre quelques expérimentations aveu
d'innovation champlan culturel donc
toujours dans le thème de créativité en
plus on va mettre
quelques thèmes un peu plus sur sur
l'activité ou sur le haut sur la
discipline scientifique et technique
les nouvelles technologies deuxième vie
sur avec des nouvelles étant de nos
jeunes aussi donc c'est pour ça que vous
avez toute une ambiance
musicale
très ciblé aussi un buzz cette
population une année souvenir pour un
centenaire celui de la grande guerre le
11 novembre 1918 a fait foisonner les
esprits créatifs peinture sculpture est
en spectacle une année de commémoration
pour ne pas oublier qu'il ya 100 ans ce
devait être la der des der
[Musique]
thelonious monk était un compositeur et
musicien brillant il est aujourd'hui
reconnu comme l'un des fondateurs du
jazz moderne
il est aussi l'hôte l'idole de laurent
de wild l'artiste français sera sur la
scène du prisme pour partager sa passion
extraits
[Musique]
du blues au rock leur style leur
révolution avec little rock story les
quatre musiciens vous font revivre
l'histoire des genres musicaux avec des
tubes planétaires les clashs ac/dc
nirvana metallica pour les écouter
rendez vous vendredi 21 décembre à
montigny le bretonneux
ils sont dix artistes à se rassembler en
un lieu le carré à la farine à
versailles jusqu'au 23 décembre
sculptures et peintures se mêlent entre
oeuvres aster abstraites et figuratives
exposition aussi à la galerie modern art
l'artiste claire baumann vous emmène en
balade à travers versailles et la nature
dans ses toiles ses aquarelles sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 27 décembre un moment
de cirque à vivre à mon tina magny les
hameaux les spécimens essaie de sauver
leur cirque un peu à la dérive un
spectacle familial décalé et drolatique
extraits merci beaucoup mesdames et
messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
reçoit l'une des plus grandes
chorégraphes contemporaines actuelle
anne teresa de keersmaeker propose une
oeuvre clé de son parcours achterland
créée en 1990 regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de ce set une culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve en
jeu en janvier 2019 pour un nouveau
numéro
en attendant je vous souhaite de passer
de très bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]
vous